the UK Supreme Court will rule tomorrow
whether Scotland can hold a new
Independence referendum without the UK
government's consent legendary actor
Brian Cox is back in the hot seat here
and has been one of the fiercestor most
famous advocates for breaking up the
Union right good evening how are you
I'm good let me see before we get into
actually ironically I don't want to
break up the union but I've got another
idea for the union United Federation
explain independent countries working in
in I mean Wales Ireland Scotland and
England because I think England gets a
lot of the tap into the bath I'm by
Nature an anglophile that's where I I
studied here in London so I'm very
disposed to that what I just believe in
is the independent states but we come
together as a United Federation is that
not what the UK is not supposed to be
but it's not because too many decisions
are made on behalf of like this major
decision that's been made in Wales about
this Chinese thing you know whether it's
supposed to be contentious there's a
dangerous element they say but the Welsh
are getting no say in the matter which I
think is really wrong so I'm all for I
don't want to break up the the union
because it's you know we are the British
Isles but I want my country not just my
country I want Wales Scotland and
England to be independent but also
interesting we had a lot of debate
obviously about to leave the European
Union and a recent survey this week in
yougov says now only 32 percent of
britons now think it was the right thing
to do to leave 56 think it was wrong
that's a massive shift absolutely but
that one that was so corrupt I mean so
rotten the whole thing and we Scotland
voted 62 to stay yes I know but does
that not give you pause for thought
about leaving no big Collective entity
which brings with it at least
you know strengthen numbers but the
north of England in who have been
systematically ignored time and time
again have have are getting you know
their well cheesed off about the fact
that they don't have enough say in their
life you know and you think of the great
things that Andy Burnham's doing in
Manchester for example and I'm more I'm
all for I'm all for the England
expressing themselves in the same way
that Scotland does and that we come
together in a proper Federation where we
contribute we don't do that now because
the rules are all set down here and the
problem I think if I was Scottish right
now given the utter Fiasco of the way
this government has behaved in the last
six months alone from Boris
we went on question time and we did
equally rage but it has been completely
shameful that we've had these three
prime ministers now Boris Johnson total
shambles with all the nonsense he got up
to Liz truss unbelievably for that short
44 days even worse tanking the economy
tanking the bound tanking everything and
now we're picking up the pieces and now
Rishi CNAC has to try and repair all the
damage but if I'm Scottish looking at
all this I'm thinking look at these
London politicians behaving like
Reckless Casino owners with our money
and we have no real say over what these
people are doing that's my point you've
just made my point well I agree but I
see that's where I have sympathy no and
that's that's the whole point but the
problem is that we that systematically
again and again and again we'll have
those guys and those gals making those
decisions you know I don't know what's
going to happen in the next election I
suppose that the probably labor will get
in but we need Vision we need real
vision and those creatures were just who
do you see who do you see out there that
you think is actually an impressive
politician who might have a vision well
I believe in Nicola sturgeon yeah I do
yes I do I think the and they've had a
lot of problems up there right don't get
me wrong they've had a lot of problems
but I do trust Nicola I think she's the
genuine article I mean I've got to say
in her credit she's always faced the
music you know I've done many interviews
with her often quite hostile she always
comes back she doesn't duck interviews
like Boris did for so many years
um she's divisive but she certainly has
what I would call leadership skills
exactly and she's a great leader and I
think she will lead us and but as I say
appears and I really mean this and
people say oh you go on about
independent Scotland I'm interested in
in the the countries in this country and
this Kingdom so-called United Kingdom
being separate being individual being
completely autonomous but they also are
part of a federation that's exactly
that's exactly what I think in the
Federation I mean who would have any
power in that would it be equal power no
it would be equal power and there'd be
there would be what would the Federation
decide that the independent autonomous
countries couldn't decide for themselves
well they well most of the stuff to
domestically they could decide for
themselves but when it comes to the
interchange with each each country then
they would have to come to some kind of
agreement it it won't be easy but it
never is what do you do for example
about currency because you wouldn't it
would take you years to go back into the
EU which is still I think what more
Scots would prefer to do but it would
take years to facilitate well I'm Bank
of England have said if you leave the UK
you can't have the pound so what do you
do it's practical level what do you do
well that's a thing that one has to
Encompass you know you're gonna have to
deal with it one way or the other but
then again we didn't go Euro uh we kept
a pound uh during this whole situation
so we we never made that we never made
that transition I don't know what would
happen in terms of but then if we had a
United Federation we would come to some
decision on that very subject that's
what about what about the Border because
we've had this nightmare from brexit of
Northern Ireland and what to do with it
there's this belief that if Scotland
really wants Independence you've got to
rebuild Hadrian's Wall are you going to
be standing there with your marauding
armor sending off the invading
but no I think that what do you do
practice again practical level what do
you do about a border if you are a
genuine independent how do you do with a
border between Belgium and France how do
you deal with the Belgium between France
and Spain would you have a physical
border you would just shut the border it
would be there you know it would be at
Hadrian's Wall which is a natural border
do you think what when you go up to
Scotland what's the mood about would you
say because the polls at the moment do
not see a majority in any of the polls
for wanting to have an independent
Scotland or indeed another referendum so
why why do you believe you're nearer to
it now than you were well I just think
because in certainly in Scotland's uh
you know I mean it changes daily you
know because there's always and the
Scots are notorious they're contentious
they can be very contentious to Scott I
know because I am one uh I was watching
Peter Capaldi the other night and he
said the great gift of my family was
family and sarcasm
and I think that's very true sorry what
was your question again I know my
question what is it about the mood in
Scotland do you think which makes you
think the polls are wrong people do want
to have I I think a genuine independent
country because we've seen what's
happened recently which has been pretty
horrific with Johnson uh you know trusts
very briefly was there did somebody else
come in well it's now Richie soon act
you know so and that party has just gone
from worse to worse to worse to worse
the worst so we don't want any trouble
with that we we're constant we're like
we're like Blanche Dubois we're always
depending on the kindness of strangers
and in a way we just need to be able to
form and also it's to do with culturally
who we are you know we're culturally
different we're not the same and you
know when I grew up in Scotland it was
North Britain and that the great thing
about Scotland and and the the SNP party
was regarded as a joke but they have
moved towards you see why I joined why I
became part of a you know Scottish I
don't like the word nationalist I've
never liked the word natural but I
believe in Scottish independence
nationalism is too contentious a word
for me but when Blair made the whole
Fiasco which we're still suffering from
in the Middle East and he got into bed
with you know uh Cheney and Rumsfeld and
the puppet as he was really Bush and uh
and Halliburton and oil I just thought
it's so obvious that this is a corrupt
thing that's happening and we should not
be part of that yeah now in Scotland we
would say no we're not going to do that
but of course we have no power we have
no power to make any opinion and I was a
labor man for a long time and I'm still
a socialist in principle but you know at
the end of the day uh that's why I think
we have to come back to ourselves it was
interesting I mean he brought up Iraq I
was editor of the Daily Mirror we
opposed the Iraq War we lost the
campaign sadly but when you look at this
Fury and Qatar what do you make of it
because my argument is that I'm not sure
we are morally pure enough here to
really be talking to the qataris about
how their laws are or anything else well
I think to a certain extent you're right
but I also think that
uh I think what's happening you know we
let's look at Iran and let's look at
what's happening in Iran where there's a
there's a sort of possible female
Revolution right and it's being led by
women right see I do think that
patriarchy is over and I think the we
need to give these women the the rights
that they deserve and we haven't done it
and I think that goes for most of the
Middle Eastern Nations but that's also
to do with religion we don't go into
that but as certainly these women need
to be freed up in a way that they're not
being freed up how would Logan Roy react
to the patriarchy he would do something
else
but I also think going back to the
question of Cutler yeah uh there that
should have been dealt with a long time
ago I mean set blatter has already
admitted it was a corrupt thing yeah so
we know it was corrupt but they should
have dealt with it a long time ago not
now this is not the point when I had
that debate before I spoke to you with
our Saka I mean when you actually do try
and work out where is morally pure
enough to have a World Cup Iceland right
I mean you're pretty much a nice and
every year right yeah and even there
have been dug deep enough with all the
world's journalists you probably find
all sorts of problems there well my
point my point being that It's Tricky
right you can't just obviously have it
nice and every year no you could well
it's not every year it's every four
years but why should the Middle East
have a World Cup no I think they should
have a World Cup but there's a lot of
stuff that's gone on I mean the Saudis
beat Argentina incredible but then think
of what the Saudis did to that
journalist in Turkey of course exactly
so then you know is there any more
morally repugnant than us illegally
invading Iraq well we haven't done that
kind of thing we haven't actually or we
legally invaded this offering country
that's what we did we did it I mean I'm
not sure there's a moral difference to
be honest yeah but but just because
there wasn't a moral difference doesn't
mean to say you have to not abandon that
issue and just saying perhaps there
needs to be a bit of morality in dealing
with things let's take a short break I
want to come back you're a Manchester
United fan I am and you saw the Ronaldo
interview I did great interview when it
gets your reaction to Ronaldo off the
break
foreign
Cox is still with me Brian you're a man
united fan the biggest star I could be
United's ever had Cristiano Ronaldo went
public in this big interview with me
let's just have a reminder of some of
the things he said
I'm trying to force you out yes not only
the coach but the other two or three
guys there around
the club
the senior executive level yes that I
felt betrayed I don't know what's going
on but since
since the saralex Ferguson left I saw
not evolution in the club the progress
was Zero the glazes they don't they
don't care about about the club the
empathy with the coach is not good I'm
I'm honest you don't have a good
relationship
I'm not mean good relationships you
think he respects you
I think you don't you don't respect the
way I should deserve you must be worried
sick I mean you I was very worried baby
son and now your baby daughter's in
hospital exactly kind of that didn't
believe
that something going wrong which is make
me feel bad really yes I am yes I didn't
believe you they believe you but in the
same way they are their peace ever gonna
change
the health of my family
for a football never
Cristiano Ronaldo that interview's not
been viewed 15 million times on our
YouTube channel
45 million more views of the clips on
social media making it one of the
biggest most watched interviews in
history certainly for sport what did you
make of it bro I mean Cristiano Ronaldo
United Legend torching really the club
um what did you think well I think it's
I can see where he's coming from
but he also has to understand that it is
not Alec Ferguson anymore it's not that
United and I could see that there was
probably a great sentimental movement to
go back to the club where he really
began where all began and Alex well you
know there's nobody there's nobody like
Alex Ferguson and Alex persuaded him and
I was just ready to come back yeah well
thinking well Alan's well naturally
because Alex loves the club and he's
trying to keep the club but the club has
gone through many so many changes in the
last few years now playing for Juventus
and playing for Real Madrid and their
clubs have been in an incredible they
haven't stopped they're just the top of
the league Manchester United has not
been playing well over the last few
years but it's beginning to get its
it's mojo back and I think it's
unfortunate that this has happened and I
is he entitled to speak out well of
course he's entitled to speak up but but
also you want us to examine exactly
where he's coming from and I think he's
coming from a place where he's saying
you know I I wanted to go back to a
beginning I wanted to go back to that
Glory Days that where when I was a young
boy and I understand he said his heart
ruled his head to it he's not ruled his
head to a degree and in a sense
that's going to be difficult and a
manager who's trying to create a new
club and there's going to be a clash and
I think it's it's it's quite tragic
actually and it's tragic for him but
it's also tragic for the club yeah you
know and I think the club has to be
given a break on this I mean I I do
think it's hard it's clearly hard
because his expectation must have been
huge and especially if Alex persuaded
him to go by that must have been a huge
thing but he's been disappointed and you
can't take away his disappointment
because it is not the same club that he
was at all those years ago have you ever
had a situation in your career when
you've been tempted to walk out have you
walked out of a a show or play a TV show
anything like that no no I just I I'm
clever enough to avoid going into those
situations have you seen people do it
yeah I've seen people walk away you know
and uh you know and I've understood why
they do it and it's it's usually complex
reasons when I did it actually well yeah
but I did it because actually when I
listened to Ronaldo I sort of thought
yeah it was he actually comes down to
respect I think it doesn't matter what
the job is if you actually feel
disrespected in your workplace that's
right and you feel you're being forced
on another way you don't want to go down
I actually think there's a certain
marriage just saying actually it's not
for me thanks yeah and I think that's
maybe I mean that this I mean I'm glad
the interviews had the the
coverage that it's had in terms of I
mean amazing 15 million is quite
incredible but at the same time I'm
going
um it's rather sad that that's the view
you're going to get because you know I
think and certainly with these kids and
with his family and you know going back
to Manchester is a difficult thing I
think losing the baby in the tragedy
with the twins and one died and one
lived that's kind of really not really
any human being and I think he wanted a
bit more of an arm wrap yeah and he
didn't get it yeah and and that's it may
just really be as simple as that yeah
um talking of arm wraps the
extraordinary series you've got on
channel five how the other half live
both rich but particularly pertinently I
thought the poor and you went down for
this series you went to Food Banks you
want to show a little clip first and ask
you about this well actually no I come
here every Friday so that I can feed my
son over the weekend but we're working
part-time and we still can't afford it
yeah my electricity has gone up from
five to four pounds a month to 170 a
month that's astronomical it really is
Hardcore and it really is we prioritize
our children and go without I think
that's yeah for all adults and parents
are doing just now really isn't it it's
shocking how Dundee has gone pretty much
full circle getting back to the poverty
I saw as a kid it's extremely painful
this stuff
you know it's painful for anybody if
you've got any sensibility at all this
stuff is painful
so they weren't you just corrected me
there they weren't food banks they're
called Community
well the difference is what people feel
about food banks is loss of dignity yeah
and the one thing that human beings have
even when they don't have any money is
some kind of dignity some kind of
feeling of who well-being of who they
are and what the community ladder does
is it charges the minimal but it means
you're paying for something so there's a
transaction not being given it you're
not being given it's not begging because
a lot of being in food banks feels like
begging and the fact that they're being
constantly legitimized is really irksome
to me but this community allowed are run
by these two amazing women who actually
run a play group and it was out of a
play group they decided to go on to this
and people like little Morrisons they
give stuff which is coming up to Itself
by date that then they can tap on and
the thing that you don't see in the
program which is one of my angers with
my editor and that anyway that's neither
here nor there but the thing you don't
see is a guy who came and at the
community ladder it was called Peter Lee
he came in and uh he was a frail man the
stick and he had a sign on his arm
and I said so you do this for your
family and he said no no I do it for
people who can't get here it was 15
people he did it for wasn't it yes
that's right he said I do it for them
and he said and I said really he said
yeah I said that's amazing he said I do
sort of five a week I do different
groups you know people who can't older
people who can't get down from the high
rises I said that's that's extraordinary
and I said so what's the sign he said
I'm blind
and I I just
almost fell off my chair and I just
thought you got quite tearful actually I
did I did because I just thought the
heroism of this guy you know this guy's
a real hero and I just thought wow you
know this man has really given something
of his life to this to this horrible
situation and trying to make it better
for us so many people in this country in
the whole of the UK are now literally on
the poverty yeah and it's probably going
to get worse before he gets 11 inflation
this energy crisis the war in Ukraine
all these things conspiring to fall out
from the pandemic you saw at the sharp
end I mean you went back to you to your
hometown and you were horrified by what
you found what do we do about this
it's a big question it's a big issue
I think
well I think Independence would help
certainly in Scotland's case but I also
think elsewhere would help I mean it
would only help if the economy yeah was
revised that's right and many economists
think that Scottish independence would
be bad for this college yeah well I I
would argue with that but I haven't got
the time to do that here but no I mean I
just I I feel that it we're going from
bad to worse but we but we
again and again and again we have
neglected our own and it's Suddenly at a
bad time now when everything is against
us the cost of living crisis what have
you the the war the in the the the
pandemic what the pandemic has done but
even so
their lives haven't changed the budget
didn't help them those people and it
never does it never does it never looks
to the poorest we don't concern
ourselves with that they're an
embarrassment let's put them over there
but now and why I wanted to do this
program was to bring it to the floor and
say these people matter and we have to
do something about it we have to have
some attitude that we haven't got that
we've kind of elbowed so long for too
long actually and that's what I feel
it's powerful stuff and I commend people
to watch it how the other half live on
channel five can't let you go without
asking you about succession one of my
favorite shows ever in the history of
television you've got a new series
coming coming in the new year can you
tell me anything or do you have to shoot
me
peers I don't have a gun
but if I did
you'd have to be shocked is Logan Roy in
series six well there isn't series six
we're only series four I know that's a
trick question
you know what let's see what happens I
mean in other words does he survive this
series well it's four you're doing now
so there's people yeah he'll survive
this year you know there'll be no
problem there's no death to be after no
no no no none of that that's all that's
all speculation and nonsense no I mean
there's a lot to be dealt with in terms
of who's going to take over and there's
a lot to be dealt with in terms of the
writers and where they can go with it
see the great thing about Jesse
Armstrong is he doesn't stay too long at
the fair right
because each season has topped the last
season so we have to keep talking it
reminds me of Aaron Sulkin on The West
Wing where the first four seasons were
fantastic then he left and the right to
collapse and the whole thing and that's
what we don't want to happen yeah would
you rather end on a high I would rather
end on a high yeah you know and leave
them wanting more lot less yes and well
you know there's a I mean I'm no names
no pactro but there's a show called
billions you know and uh Damien Lewis
left and they're still going on yeah I
know but it's it's overrigging the
souffle that's what I would call a wee
bit how many times a day do you get told
to tell people to f off all the time
like a dozen times I was at the Scottish
Baptist last night and it was I couldn't
get away from people and of course as I
said before it's the it's the
the best thing to tell people yes
because when you're fed up with them you
go
you can say it won't bleep you oh
and finally as a Scott who do you most
want to win the World Cup England or
Wales
um or somebody else
uh
I have to reserve judgment on that oh
come on no no I'm not I can't do that do
you want England to beat say you know I
think I think I I'd like to see England
do well because I think he's done a
great job yeah I think he's really done
a great job and there's some great
players we've got a few good Arsenal
players in there yeah
what a player tremendous I was worried
about him because he got uh a couple of
games ago they they took his legs from
him and I thought oh God he's made a
tough stuff uh Brian brilliant to see
you